northern israel has killed at least 44
people the crash happened at a gathering
for tens of thousands of ultra-orthodox
jews
on mount meron our correspondent harry
fawcett's near the scene he's going to
be updating us shortly first this report
from sarah khalid
emergency services rushed to the scene
where tens of thousands of
ultra-orthodox jews had gathered for the
lag bomber annual pilgrimage
what started off as an all-night
gathering of prayer and dance at the
bonfire festival
ended with these chaotic scenes
bodies of those killed in a stampede are
lined up hundreds of people are injured
provided first aid to those who injured
the site we sent out backup teams
200 ambulances motorcycles mobile
intensive care units helicopters
to the scene to transport and evacuate
those were injured and killed
to the hospitals considered to be one of
the holiest sites for jews the tomb of
the second century sage rabbi shimon
bayoche is what brings the faithful here
around 30 000 pilgrims were gathered on
mount meron
three times the capacity of what was
allowed by the authorities
organizers say more than 650 buses had
brought in people from across the
country
making it the largest public gathering
in israel since the pandemic started
all of a sudden we saw paramedics from
madame whatever running by
like mid cpr on kids and then one after
the other started coming on ambulances
then we understood like something's
going on here
private bonfires at mount [ __ ] were
banned last year due to coronavirus
restrictions
the lockdown measures were eased this
year after israel's rapid covert 19
vaccination programme
has seen more than 50 percent of the
population fully vaccinated
police say they've arrested two people
for disrupting officers efforts to keep
order at the site
and israeli prime minister benjamin
netanyahu has described the stampede as
a heavy disaster
al jazeera okay let's talk to harry
fawcett who's on the scene harry sat his
package they're just showing us some of
the chaos and fear
that there was at the event what's the
latest that we know about this
well yes it was a dreadful event as you
just saw in those pictures and it's been
written on the faces of some of the
people we've been speaking to
here as well we had been barred from
getting further access than this police
checkpoint until just a couple of
minutes ago when they've
said that we can get further in but all
the way up to here we've been seeing
stragglers from the events overnight
trying to get lifts getting on buses
and we've talked talked to a couple of
them uh one young man said that it was a
crime carried out by the police
accusing the police of preventing uh
people from uh
from getting access to one potential
exit route
out of the the crush another man said
that he had watched it
take place from a distance and he saw
people
slipping down a series of steps uh on
top
of each other uh and that it was uh
you know an unavoidable consequence of
that that there were going to be
deaths and injuries i also asked him
if he had ever felt unsafe at this event
before
this is an event that attracts some half
a million people over a series of days
every year not last year because of the
pandemic but but in a typical year
and he said yes every time he said it
was a miracle that nothing like this
had happened before because of the lack
of organization because of the
difficulty of access for emergency
services uh and for the sheer sort of
chaos and crush
that attends each time that this biggest
religious
festival in israel takes place so as
well as the buses who have been coming
which have been coming to
evacuate the last remaining festival
goes there have also been buses
bringing more police in to carry out a
major investigation into how this
happened
and there will be answers uh that will
be sought from
quarters both in terms of the organizers
in terms of the police in terms of the
government for
allowing this to go ahead in such great
numbers in such
a small under-resourced under-equipped
it seems sight
harry i know we're going to be coming
back to you in the next few hours as
this unfolds but for now thanks very
much indeed
palestine's first parliamentary
elections in 15